Professor Martin Hartman was supposed to
be at university today but the
kindergarten she uses is closed so she's
working from home someone has to stay
home and look after the children no good
no fortunately her partner Holger showed
says here and can help out he has a
professorship in Copenhagen and has to
spend three days a week away from home a
challenging situation for everyone
involved it kept me off there's only
really i also have thought about whether
it would be better to cut back or do
something else those thoughts only
really start once you've had children
but there's also the fact that i really
love my job and I don't want to stop
working so I have to live with my guilty
conscience and with the chaos that
regularly ensues I just have to cope led
to leave it to inflation give isn't
leaving on time it was one onion hartman
works whenever her home life allows
that's the only way she can balance kids
teaching and research there's abbott
working evenings at home is very
important so I can organize everything
because I have to pick up the kids in
the afternoon so once they're in bed i
work until 11 or so at night the
couple's day begins before 6am when he's
home Holger takes care of the kids and
the housework
yeah yeah IDK pokemon that allows his
partner to keep appointments in the
evening or on the weekend they're
crucial if she's to pursue her career in
germany d that's why I long to zagging
many people think that only men can
pursue a career and women can only have
a part time job because they're supposed
to take care of the household and the
children I think that silly I think
people in Germany had to extreme in
their views of motherhood it's different
in other countries tility does motor
shaft bombs didn't swim phenomenal
indeed indeed nichkhun in denmark where
Holger works it's common practice for
men to leave the workplace at 5pm if
they have to pick up their kids business
meetings are scheduled to end earlier
Germany is different professor Hartman
is going into work at her Institute she
has a series of meetings with coworkers
and she has to give lectures do research
and publish a fountain my husband in job
interviews I've been asked what I've
been doing over the past three years and
I've been told that it's less than my
male competitors and when I say I had
children during those years the response
is and so what ya know whether it's in
universities or companies attitudes like
that pressure young women into choosing
between kids and careers I can click as
a central's Odyssey mask actually most
women in this situation say that it's a
massive challenge in menacing and the
pressure is increased even more because
they have to act as if there's no
conflict talker who just wants a tunnel
is always this assumption that you'll be
able to find time for all your
commitments little disputed cialis like
that each owner problema
in the afternoon professor Hartman finds
time for her children but as soon as
they go to sleep at night she's back at
her desk for me personally if it's
personally I wouldn't have it any other
way but it's only since I've had kids
that I understand emotionally why some
women don't want any if you really want
to build a career that combination isn't
great